so the fundamental policy problem is how
can we collect the information we all
have about the consequences of our
choices so that we can all pull it
together into a form that we can share
and use and if you look at the various
kinds of institutions we've ever used in
the world to collect information and
share it together into a consistent form
that we can use together the institution
that seems to consistently work the best
is speculative markets betting markets
stock markets currency markets commodity
markets these markets have consistently
take in given people the incentive to
find things out bring the information
they have to bear to this Center which
is the market include their information
in the current market price and then
allow that current market price to be
information spread everywhere that tells
us all what we all know so we've had
many tests where we have had a betting
market or speculative market price
compared at the same time to other
institutions that we often use like
committees or expert surveys or all
sorts of other mechanisms and basically
we have many dozens of these comparisons
and consistently what we find is that
either they're both about the same in
terms of the accuracy of their forecasts
or the betting market is substantially
better more accurate
that's the consistent data we have now
we have some good theoretical reasons
for understanding why but I don't want
to make the picture to be based on that
theory it seems safer to make the pitch
based on the empirics
consistently these betting market prices
beat now you can understand in the sense
that what they do is they offer a
challenge to anybody they say look at my
price if you think this is wrong come
fix it and you will make money and
that's not only true with respect to
sort of base things you might know about
a factory burning down or something else
it's about the patterns like do prices
go up on Mondays too much do they go
down when it rains too much etc and any
pattern you can find where you can see a
mistake in the market you can make money
by betting on that pattern
go away and that's the powerful
incentive the speculative markets offer
and in general but we've had a specular
markers just on the random topics that
have arose in like the price of gold or
IBM but we can make a spending market on
purpose on a topic you care about say
even covin kovat infections and then get
the information on the question you care
about so for example you have a project
with a deadline you want to know will I
make the deadline
typically you ask people on the project
will it make the deadline when you get
back as a politically correct responsive
whatever the leader wants you to think
which is typically yes we'll make the
deadline and if you say something else
you might get punished for it you know
by that the person running it for
violating their their dogma but if you
have betting markets which people can
bet anonymously then you tend to get the
accurate forecast
so we consistently see that people get
accurate forecasts and more accurate
forecasts when we have betting markets
on things and there's an enormous
potential for this to be applied across
society and institutions especially
through what I call conditional betting
markets or decision markets and I've
given the name future key to sort of
governance that way and the key idea is
that you can bet on the outcome of a
decision conditional in which decision
is made and many markets and that can
basically tell you which decision to
make so my favorite example is firing
the CEO so you have a company you have a
CEO should you keep the CEO or should
you fire them well usually a board makes
that decision but that's relatively
political and it seems like we make a
lot of mistakes there so the idea is you
have a stock market where people trade
on stock and then you have a stock
market where you let them trade on the
stock conditional on whether or not we
keep the CEO we have two prices the
price of the stock if we keep the CEO
the price that stock if we don't and the
difference of those prices tells us
should we keep the CEO and that would be
a straightforward way to give us advice
on a key decision and we could do that
everywhere and so the bottom line is we
have a lot of data on prediction markets
in many different contexts showing that
they basically work we have a lot of
innovations of
better ways to make them work better and
new context we have a lot of tests of
those but what we don't have as a lot of
adoption and the key problem is that
they are very politically disruptive so
for example if you think about this
person with a deadline and wanting to
know if he'll make the deadline he can
make a prediction market on them on the
project and that will tell them whether
they or make the deadline but the person
writing the project cares more about
having a good excuse if he fails then
lowering the chance of failing and so
typically a person with the project
deadline their best excuse if they fail
will be to say well things were going
along fine and then at the last minute
something came out of left field no one
could see him coming not the flat it's
so rare and strange it'll never happen
again so there's no need to hold anyone
responsible here let's just continue on
and the person running the project wants
that to be the excuse and their boss and
even boss's boss wants that to be the
excuse because they all would look bad
if they were in charge of a project that
failed for it's just you know a reason
that could have been prevented so if you
make a prediction market on this project
you could even do conditional versions
which will tell you how to make the
project more likely to make a deadline
but the key problem is if the market
says you won't make the deadline it'll
tell you long in advance consistently
and then you can't have this excuse that
at the last minute we were not buy
something at all I feel
everybody could say look the market told
you you were gonna fail you didn't you
didn't prevent the failure you're at
fault and that's an example of how in
our world political disruption of
prediction markets tends to make people
not want to adopt them that is most
people running projects and running
organizations care more about defending
themselves from lighting than they do
about making the overall organization
work off it - reminds me a lot of the
book super forecasters and would it be
fair to say that you think the stock
market is a prediction market as it
exists in today's form or does it not
fit that definitely it does but the
thing it's predicting is not very easy
to interpret you know it's like if
aliens have a betting market and you
could see the prices in the betting
market but you didn't understand what
the
words were on the BET's then you
wouldn't be able to make much useful
right so the stock market is a bet on
the value of that company but that's a
complicated thing and so it's hard to
apply that insight and information to
other things you care about so the more
that we can make betting and speculative
markets more directly on the things we
care about including especially the
decisions we make the more we useful we
can make them and how does this get
applied to government obviously that is
like the ultimate decision making
machine that probably has them the
widest impact on a citizen's life how do
we incorporate the ideas of a prediction
market into that bureaucratic process
well mechanically it wouldn't be that
hard to do the harder problem is do
people want to so what I recommend is
that we start with small-scale
experiments and work our way up so
instead of trying initially to apply
prediction markets to government we
apply them to small clubs small
companies small organizations and slowly
show through a long you know detailed
track record that this works and in each
case try to entice neighboring
organizations and slightly bigger
versions to copy what it seems to have
worked at a smaller scale and then
eventually we could get government so as
you may know government isn't usually
the initiator of a lot of innovations in
society well it tends to belatedly copy
them when something works well enough
elsewhere and so that's probably the
best route to produce innovation as
government is to produce in a similar
innovation in the private sector and
then shame the government in the copy
but in order to inspire people about
what should be eventually possible I do
sometimes describe government
applications to give you a sense of just
how far this could go so for example the
simple simplest thing might be just
there are many government projects with
budgets that lie that is there's an
official budget but then later on
they're gonna come back and ask for some
more money and they didn't admit ahead
of time they wanted that extra money but
they kind of knew so you can have a
betting market on the budget for a
project that says well eventually how
much will this cost and
could even have that conditional if we
adopt this project how much will it cost
eventually and now we can get a more
honest budget on how much things will
cost and of course people who are
pushing these projects now don't want
that to happen because they tend to want
to to convince us to adopt their project
by believing it will cost as much as it
really well
now freeways cost more and you know all
sorts of NASA projects cost more than
they all initially announced so that's
just one simple example of how you can
use it but these conditional versions of
the market would let us make big key
decisions like you might justify
building a stadium by saying oh look at
all the revenue we'll have if we have a
stadium but we might say well if we
build a city how much revenue will we
really have over these coming years and
then that could be more discipline our
choice of do we build the stadium we
could even do this at the you know
presidential election level we could
have betting markets and say that it's
the to a Republican and Democrat you
know what are the outcomes you care
about pandemic deaths war deaths GDP you
know stock market whatever it is even
international respect we could have
betting markets in each of these things
conditional on which candidate is
elected actually today there are betting
markets for which nominee should each
party produce if they want to win the
election so there are many markets on
who will win the election and also on
who will be nominated and you just have
to divide those two numbers to get the
probability of being elected if
nominated so those many markets could be
much thicker and much more accurate and
then they would give a much stronger
message to each party of who to nominate
of course the parties are pretending
that they really want to win but often
the insiders care more about who's
nominated than who wins so they may not
welcome such things